One afternoon, as she was walking around in downtown Udacity, Athena happened
upon a soda machine. And it looked so enticing that she decided to grab a drink.
All the drinks from the soda machine cost $1.00. She put a dollar in the machine
slot, pressed a button for which drink she wanted. And voila, out came a soda.
She tasted her drink and since it was so delicious, she decided to buy one for
her brother too, since she was about to stop by his house. So, she put another
dollar in the machine and she got a second can of soda for him. Now, since the
price per soda has the set value, a constant, of $1. What are two variable that
we could very easily related to one another with an equation that uses this
constant? Please pick two of these five choices down here. Would you want to use
level of thirstiness, amount of money Athena puts in the machine, how hard
Athena presses the button, how many brothers Athena has, or how many sodas the
machine spits out? Which two of these belong together along with this constant
of $1.00?